Water scarcity affects more than 40 percent
of the global population.
Water scarce regions in particular struggle
with crop failure,
soil degradation and,
if it rains, with floods.
Land-based rainwater harvesting is one solution
to the water scarcity problem.
It entails the collection of water and
subsequent storage in reservoirs
or directly within the soil profile.
This rainwater harvesting method can be classified
into micro-catchment and macro-catchment harvesting.
In micro-catchment rainwater harvesting,
rain falls onto a small catchment area
and flows directly to the adjacent cropped basin,
where a single tree, bush
or row of crops is planted.
The purpose of this is to store water
in the root zone,
to provide enough water for the plants
throughout the growing period.
There are various ways of implementing
micro-catchment rainwater harvesting.
One is strip catchment tillage,
which consists of alternating rows
of cultivated crops
with rows of uncultivated grass.
The grass acts as a catchment to collect rainwater
and then drains it to the crops next to it.
Contour or keyline barriers are constructed
perpendicular to the slope.
Their function is to intercept rainfall,
encourage infiltration, and to reduce soil erosion.
Barriers are built from vegetative material
in trashlines, stones or soil.
Other cross-slope systems are swales
and living terraces.
Basin systems are closed diamond
or square shaped catchments,
surrounded by low earth bunds.
Water falling into this basin is channelled
to the lowest point,
where ideally food trees are grown.
In macro-catchment rainwater harvesting,
the catchment area lies
outside the application area.
This means the rain is not collected
where it is used.
The land cover of the catchment area
can be manifold,
including cultivated land,
roads or settlements.
Often, the catchment area is located
on a hill or mountain slope.
To provide water in dry periods,
the collected water can either be used
for groundwater recharge
or stored in open or closed systems
like farm ponds or underground tanks.
There are three broad categories of
macro-catchment rainwater harvesting systems.
The first are hillside systems.
Here, water flowing downhill
accumulates on barriers,
where it is used for crop irrigation
and groundwater recharge.
In stream-bed systems,
structures such as sand dams or check dams
are constructed across temporarily flooded channels.
They are built from upstream to downstream
to reduce the force of the water flow,
to infiltrate water
and to control erosion.
Ephemeral stream diversion systems divert
water from seasonally flooded channels
to large, low-lying areas,
where the water infiltrates
and provides enough moisture for crop growth.
Land-based rainwater harvesting contributes
to the reduction of soil erosion and flood occurrence,
while also enhancing groundwater recharge.
Where climate change and mismanagement
threaten the availability of water as a resource,
rainwater harvesting systems can help
increase agricultural activity
and thus food availability.